i'm not even being sarcastic i'm i'm
more you've lost 50 pounds bro you're
doing better
if you just got on the debate right now
is our ivy league people smarter than
the average person and
does obama think he's better than others
simply because he went to an ivy league
school and i'm saying no gerard saying
yes i don't know we can maybe maybe talk
about it most important thing about
today's podcast most importantly about
today's podcast
listen very closely because you may save
some money on your taxes based on a
special tip we're going to give you with
the irs yes i know it's a big gift
don't spoil it adam
massive tip will show don't bury the
lead biz doc momentarily okay so we got
adam uh tom and gerard here yeah how was
your morning pat uh tell us about your
morning had a soccer game i don't know
why they're putting soccer games this
early what time was it
on thursday
uh practice started at seven something
game starts at uh almost eight o'clock
and then boom they're going at it for 45
minutes and i barely made it so i'm 15
minutes away from here how do you do
how'd the kid do he uh first half didn't
play they didn't have the shin guards
second half he played and uh he did good
they won the game uh five uh they were
winning 5-1 when i left with two minutes
left
that's a shellacking his team is filled
with brazilians and he's the only middle
eastern one so
yeah you ever seen the movie kicking and
screaming with will ferrell
hey juice box mike ditka yeah yeah and
they recruited the two italian kids
that's what's going on over there in
westminster you know kids you know
people talk a lot about kids being over
scheduled and then your local soccer
club i mean brooke got it okay brook who
plays defender she's right there in
front of the goalie usually captain of
the defense thank you carolina when they
miss when they miss a game they do the
same thing pat brooke has had like a 11
o'clock
sunday game 10 o'clock sunday game and
then like a two o'clock sunday game and
they run these double headers and these
are the same parents who are complaining
that the kids are over scheduled who are
with their local soccer group putting
double headers very seriously by the way
they do take it seriously if anybody
knows
a great i'm not talking an average
anybody knows the best
soccer coach to coach uh uh to my kids
i am looking for a killer one i'm not
looking for a regular one i'm looking
forward to it okay yeah i'm looking for
somebody here south florida if you know
it the emmy send me a yes exactly i got
you pat within fifth we got you i'll
give you this guy's been saying i got
you ever since we've been in south
florida all of adam's friends are going
to be showing up we haven't seen anybody
yet the problem is we're not in south
florida we're in like north florida
yesterday we had an ideation meeting
folks you got to hear this okay
we've done a great meeting it was a
great meeting we've had four strategy
sessions okay to come up with ideas
adam's been on every single one of them
adam's powerpoint
is the same powerpoint for two and a
half years straight he is convinced we
need to change valuetainment's name to
girls attainment that's what he's
convinced his one slide says girls girls
girls girls like the beastie boys or van
halen
all right so today's stories and by the
way i'm not wrong yeah listen who do you
think had the best presentation
yesterday i could go for some real talk
uh who do i think had the best
presentation
it pains me but you crushed it dude you
really do appreciate
your idea at the end i think was the
best implementable idea immediately yeah
by far all right we're gonna if that's
he wasn't so much a fan of it because he
hates competition he hates capitalism we
all know gerard but the capitalist who
doesn't like competition that's what it
is
we're only two minutes into this and
you're already all right we're fired up
pat do we have a list pat yes we do so
in october home prices go up 18.4
in november home prices fall and
yesterday on the call people were asking
the same pat what do you think is going
to happen with real estate in 2022
should i expect deposit the thing the
negative thing maybe we'll talk about
that a little bit fauci says you should
consider mandating vaccines for domestic
air travel
uh but doesn't expect it for now
one-third of programmers folks listen up
especially if you're a programmer maybe
if you are going to listen if you're a
programmer maybe if you're one of these
third programmers you're probably not
listening but one third of programmers
use marijuana while working
with many touting creative benefits that
he finds okay we'll talk about that for
sure just lane maxwell we got some
things to talk about with her
uh nfl legend john madden dies at 85
we'll talk about him uh every doordash
employee from engineer to ceo will be
making deliveries and one of their
employees who makes four hundred
thousand dollars you complain about the
fact that the company white initiative
requires them to deliver one thing per
month he's upset about it
mom of a child allegedly abused by cnn
producer john griffin is outraged by the
delayed arrest
uh
she's furious and on top of that another
thing came out today by the way i don't
know if you guys saw that story that
just popped up tyler did you see the
story of uh
the other producer of cnn go pull it up
so we can talk about that as well talk
about the cuomo producer this is another
one oh this is another one tesla owner
blows up tesla owner blows up tesla
owner blows up uh his car after 22 000
repair now the reason why i believe this
story is because the guy was from norway
so it's a believable story we got some
stuff going on with cdc from 10 to 5
days
north korea has hacked 1.7 billion
dollars worth of cryptocurrency from
exchanges and considers it a long-term
investment
there you go
facebook and instagram band thomas payne
saying he's a revolutionary guy harry
reid also passed away rest in peace
uh huge surge in house democrats 2022
retirement announcements as 2021 comes
around and cdc uh this is the first time
they've ever done this they made a
mistake overestimating omicron spread by
more than 200 percent and uh trump's got
a few things to say about mitch
mcconnell which we'll get into anyways
let's get right into the tax tip folks
tax season is around the corner
a very story came out yesterday about
taxes get your paper and pen ready this
may uh uh uh help somebody you know
uh because irs is actually serious about
this irs says
to report stolen property as income
unless you could return it the same year
this is a fox 4 news kansas city story
it's also usa today story an image
circulating on social media purpose that
to show an iris guideline asking
taxpayers to report any value of any
property they've stolen each year as
income the guideline is real the irs
publication 17 available on agency's
website contains a section on stolen
property that may leave readers
scratching if you can pull up the
picture so people can't see it here's
what it looks like
illegal activities income from illegal
activities such as money from dealing
drugs illegal drugs must be included in
your income as schedule one
stolen property if you steal property
you must report it
in your income in the near in the year
you stole it unless it unless in the
same year you choose to return it to its
rightful owner so that's your tax tip of
the day tom what are your thoughts on
this well what i think is going to
happen is you're going to have some dumb
criminals and there are those
and they're going to turn in their taxes
they're going to say thank you very much
for paying your taxes we've forwarded
this to the fbi have a nice day
i mean these guys talk i mean this is
it's it's either a joke or a hook
but i i can't believe the literal the
literalness
that it's in the code yeah so so uh uh
the uh years ago they said capone got
caught like this wow this is how they
caught capone they came out with a law
like this
and then they fell forward and yeah so
tax evasion is what it is but this is
slightly different than tax evasion you
steal a car report it i made 17 000
dollars because they stored seventeen
thousand dollar cards what's the what's
the uh depreciation on right vehicle i
got so this is not an onion headline
this is actual real stuff because it
seems like an onion headline if there's
ever been one
those of you that joined in a riot and
got yourself three or four of those
70-inch tvs took them home remember
those seem like tax-paying citizens
right exactly remember remember that's
three grand each that's nine grand needs
to be on line 16 of your tax form yeah
no it's okay i had i
said i i have a c corp that i do all of
my theft under so we're just going to be
you know
that seriously
yeah first time i saw this i thought it
was a joke yeah i'm not even kidding
with you by the way i posted it
yesterday on instagram tulsi gabbard
responded yeah and she said i had to did
you see what she said no she said i went
online to verify this it's unbelievable
that it's real that's what kelsey said
this is the national uh or the
government website there you go that's
the website
put the link in comment section so
people want to go to they can go honest
to god though i mean all jokes aside
this tells you everything you need to
know about progressive america right now
because they don't care about you me or
this fellow citizen steal from you just
make sure you give us a little bit but
you know what i love
you know it's all right burn down a
business just don't come anywhere near
the capitol ah you know mostly people
over there just don't do it here that's
who these people are it's a let them eat
cake
the regulations are an exercise in
comedy look at what's right below the
stolen property transporting school
children don't include in your income a
school board mileage allowance for
taking children to and from school so in
other words you cannot deduct mileage
for taking kids back and forth to school
but you must declare that property
imagine like what
what world are we even living in anymore
i mean even even the mayor of san
francisco a far-left progressive mayor
she's like oh lyndon yeah yeah london
london it's like
these policies i don't even know like we
got 13 billion dollars and we're we've
got everybody on the same page
everybody's in the same party and uh
we've got nothing but crime theft human
[ __ ] and and people sleeping in the
streets maybe i don't know maybe we need
those and shooting smack yeah
by the way you said you know there's
going to be some drug dealers out there
that have stolen stuff that they're
going to put this on their taxes zero
people are doing this zero zero nobody's
like smoking weed sitting there with
their stolen goods
all their drug money around them i'm
like sorry baby i'm doing my c corp
taxes right now like
not happening
people are doing this
and then pays their taxes
who's taking inventory on what they
stole in a riot who's taking inventory
like well that's one guys there's no
receipts there's no receipts
underestimating the amount of uh dummies
we have in america you are really giving
people way too much credit there's a lot
of people
that will you ever seen the the what is
the video that says the dummy criminal
of the week or the dummy yeah there is
plenty of strange
stupid criminals that think they can get
away the biggest voluntary taxes i don't
even think these criminals are filing
taxes they're much less voluntarily
admitting theft i'm just telling you
don't underestimate you guys okay only
the paranoid survivor i think people
exactly imagine getting away
people are actually going to do this
remember
i want to interview the two people that
do it
if i were a criminal which i'm not or if
i were a drug dealer which i'm not and i
wouldn't want to give this corrupt
government any money what i would do
instead of and again this is just i know
right
is i would take those assets and i may
or may not invest in some ethereum and
then use that ethereum to create an nft
and then take that nft and sell it to
myself at a loss so then i don't know we
got him pat we got him we got him
defense let's go call him up by the way
adam call him up open the door they're
coming all right so let's go to the next
store and they're not going to be high
while they're you know filling out their
tax returns what we've already
determined is they're high coding from
microsoft absolutely
so that leads us to the next story which
is perfect right there tom so one third
of programmers using marijuana while
working with many touting
creative benefits study finds this is a
story
uh from the marijuana moment okay
uh researchers at university of michigan
said that the anecdotal evidence
suggested that those in programming were
more likely to use cannabis on the job
so they set out to conduct a first large
scale survey on the topic this provision
of cannabis used in software engineering
has contributed to a widely reported
hiring shortage for certain us
government programming jobs the study
finds 53 said they've consumed cannabis
while working and programming at least
12 times 27 said they use it at least
twice a week and four percent say they
use it while working on a daily basis
okay
good thing bad thing funny story who
cares where you at with this i'll tell
you where i'm at with this
and speaking from experience from
creative benefits when i was in my
stand-up comedy days i did two things
three things all day every day i would
smoke weed and when i was living in
denver i would write jokes half of them
were absolutely ridiculous half of them
i used on stage i would uh then go play
basketball in the afternoon
in the mile high city literally and uh
and then i would go do stand up at night
and it really does help
your creative
juices flow the problem with that is
though you know you smoke your weed and
then like three hours later you're like
it's time for a nap it's like dude it's
noon what are you doing
so there are creative benefits for it
but the downside is you lose energy you
lose stamina you lose your ability to
like keep going and
and keep pushing somebody that maybe has
experience david what do you think about
it
no joke uh i have a friend his name is
mavid
and uh
i was doing sound design for this film
and uh i mean he was doing sound design
for this film and he got really high and
he thought it was dope and then he sent
it and the guy was like hey buddy uh was
this like a first draft or something
this sounds like dog [ __ ] it was
terrible so it doesn't make you creative
everybody
uh i don't think you would do that well
by the way we'd love to meet schmavit
yeah one of yeah
yeah he's super busy though
am i the only one that thought one-third
was like low yeah
i think it's like way more well what
percentage of americans do you think
have smoked weed oh a lot dude i'm
actually probably one of the only one of
my friends that doesn't like weed like
i've never in my i swear to god but you
do like the munchies that's my dude
that's the whole thing i've never needed
any ambition to be lazy and hungry in my
life i've got lazy and hungry covered
have you ever smoked weed i don't need
your help and what did it do for you
because you're the type of person that
does not need cocaine
you're going regardless
uh i can promise you uh uh i have to
there's nothing about cocaine that does
me good because if you cut my blood
there's probably some coconut in there
because natural
assyrian uh uh uh sugar that's gonna be
in there no you know wheat was
never smoked in high school never smoked
in the military i got out i uh
was dating this girl she was my boss and
one night we smoked weed and
i finished three bowls of berries
like literally i finished three bowls of
berries at night at one o'clock in the
morning that's the only story i remember
and it's probably very good for a guy
like me you serious yeah you guys would
benefit from me smoking weed even though
i think at the end of the day when you
do smoke
man is it even still a big deal anymore
they came out they said a large
percentage i don't say a large
percentage a lot of companies have done
away with drug tests they should they're
just like come to work we need you biz
doc for someone that smokes weed every
day what do you think of this
story um excuse me
well first of all david thank you for
not saying your friend's last name no
one will figure out who this guy is she
maybe
yeah
there's the only guy in south florida
with the name but um
no i think um you look at it
you look at who's in the dispensaries
you look at the people that are going
into and the interview you're finding
people you have to remember the people
that were high at woodstock what are
they now that's 1969 they're in charge
of our government they're the baby
blacks yes they're 80 years old they're
75 to 82 years of boomers and so you've
got people all the way up to that age
remembering this and
i've always felt that if you're going to
legalize this we need to regulate it
paraquat hurt a lot of people it was a
pesticide that was in it if you're going
to legalize it then let's make it like
any food product or ingesting product
let's put some standards on it but let's
also figure out a way to make sure if
you're driving completely stoned and
putting people at risk we can test for
that and so
i have always felt if we're going to
legalize it let's legalize it the whole
way and let's also protect ourselves and
people how do you test for for driving
stones well there's already i mean
driving impaired is already a law so i
mean it's that is a law but it is a law
but reliable tests for
sure but even right now where it's
decriminalized in california there's
still a black market because the taxes
are so high they're asking for the taxes
to come down in california because the
drug dealers are still selling dimebags
for you know for ten bucks so i'll tell
you a quick story
i'll tell you a quick story about
driving stoned and this is what i
realized dude don't be smoking and
driving over here i went first i
shouldn't be driving period yeah that's
great i agree i agree i should not be
trying yeah why don't you i've had a car
in 10 years i was 22 years old getting
the carrier thing and let the cat drive
thank you yeah i was 22 years old and i
remember
i did not smoke all throughout high
school and in college and i was like i'm
a drug free i'm an athlete and then i
got i was playing college football and
all my teammates were getting stoned and
and doing all sorts of nonsense but this
one day i went to get in my car i was i
had to go run some errands and i get my
car and i go to put the key in the
ignition and i'm sitting in shotgun
i'm sitting in the passenger seat in my
car so they're you know you just brought
up a great [ __ ] so when i was when i was
don't be driving huh folks he's just
trying to make this up this happens
every week okay this is not 20 years ago
this was last week but what's crazy is
like i think we all agree like as far as
like drugs are concerned
it's pretty obvious at this point that
wheat is pretty low on the list of of
things that can like they call it what
is it a grade a what are they called or
whatever the dea whatever whatever they
can do to keep themselves in business
but the
the
the issue becomes you talked about
school
we'd stayed in your system for testing
for 30 plus days there wasn't like a
single athlete i knew that smoked weed
but instead we would do all the harder
[ __ ] the stuff that's way worse for you
because
24 yeah so it was like and dude
especially if you got injured if you got
injured or you were dealing with
soreness or something like that instead
of smoking weed you would you would take
oxies and you would take like pills that
are hardcore that have you talked about
this before i think we can all agree
that on the level of things that people
use
weed is way better for you than alcohol
or pills is it not but it comes out of
the ground it doesn't come out of a lab
so i mean it's there's profit incentive
for them to get kids hooked on on pills
that need prescriptions there's still
profit incentive in
in the greens though isn't there
well tax that we depends on on who's
who's in there but yeah i mean listen
what i think is interesting man is like
i told this to pat i'm not i'm not going
to say the guy's name david but i know a
guy who's a shmurard incredibly good
like 12 to 1600 a day editor for a major
network and he micro doses lsd the whole
day oh yeah well this is common
i don't think is it common micro dosing
let me let me ask you no i don't i i
told you in the morning let me ask you
let me ask you a different question let
me ask you a different question a
serious question okay
i'm a 22 year old kid listening to this
i'm a driven guy i want to do big things
forget about the guy that's not
ambitious that doesn't want to do
anything with his life and he just wants
to kick back you don't need to tell them
you couldn't motivate the guy even if
you brought all the best motivational
speakers in the room
i'm a 22 year old kid i really want to
do something big with my life
we're all in our 30s and 40s here and
some of us are maybe not in our 40s and
30s but
in the room here you get you can give
this advice to somebody at 20 20 22
years old what would you tell this kid
eat clean about drugs what would you
tell them about drugs
stick to the natural stuff what would
you what would you tell them about drugs
look uh i've done drugs i've done
i grew up in south beach i've done uh i
i'm not if i always tell this story that
the the only reason i'm alive right now
is i don't like cocaine i mean everyone
in miami is cocained out and that's how
they reason they they party i would say
this
um
get your [ __ ] done focus on what is
actually important like work
get your you know but if if you're doing
well and you want to go out on the
weekends
again i think smoking a joint is way
better than getting wasted and just
taking a fifth to the head on alcohol
your 18 year old son you're going to
tell him that
i would say i'd rather him smoke a joint
then drink a liter of alcohol you're
okay with them smoking without 18
they're going to do it anyway real talk
i mean how many 50 wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute hang on a second
wrong assumption you didn't do it till
you were out of college right correct
okay so you when you say they're going
to do it anyways we don't know that i'm
saying what would you say gerard what
would you say uh i think
dude unfortunately man i think this is
one of those things where people need to
touch the stove to realize how hot it is
like every time i did drugs every time i
got drunk every time i got messed up i
didn't have a bad time but every time i
had the worst night of my life i was
high or i was i was drunk or i was
messed up so it's not like every time
you do something you ruin your life but
every time you ruin your life you're on
some [ __ ] you know you know what's so
you know what's the thing i would say is
the following here's the one thing
here's i remember i can tell you crystal
clear
every single time where i was at when a
kid said here smoke a cigarette i said i
don't want to smoke a cigarette my mom
and dad smoke two packs a day every day
from the day i was born in our house in
our car everybody smoked two packs a day
two packs a day okay in iran okay
so we've been a cardinal white renault
mom and dad are smoking cigarettes the
whole you know what the hotbox and stuff
i mean we've been i had secondhand uh uh
ask my dad the story look what he'll
tell you you're saying hot boxing
cigarettes
it's not just my parents it's not just
my parents remember remember in
airplanes they used to have uh ashtrays
and you're saying back now with vapes
you go into a bar in downtown
deep here's everybody here's what i'm
gonna tell you so so that was cigarettes
that that was a he liked his alcohol he
every day he drank a glass like this of
a ori i don't know how you describe what
oh he is 60 i mean it was 60 proof it's
legit stuff that you're talking about
okay
so uh and you guys know how much i love
my dad so this isn't something he would
tell you these stories himself right
okay go to high school i see guys
smoking cigarettes i'm like i'm good
guys you guys smoke cigarettes i've had
the chance to smoke cigarettes since i
was six months old you guys i've
probably been smoking more cigarettes
and both of you guys combined so then
the wheat situation comes out you want
to smoke weed i'm good
then the the the other couple of the
situations comes up one time i was about
i was a uh i don't know if i've told the
story here
uh i'm working at valleys this one guy
that's working there he's always got
these s500s parked outside he's got a
boat he's got a yacht
but he never sells memberships and he's
a salesperson selling drugs he's making
675 an hour i'm like how the hell
so one day i'm like i don't want to say
the guy let's say his name is my michael
very good friend tyler
no let's say his name is michael one day
i said michael can we go to quiz we go
he would never let me pay
i'm like dude you're not making money
i said let me go dude i got you you're
cool it says no this house don't
yeah i'd go to quiz oh so he says i said
i said i got you pete don't worry about
it so he pays for 10 years older than me
i said dude michael how the hell you
make all this money
he said what are you doing this saturday
i said i'm open he said let's go
somewhere so we go saturday introduce me
to the top uh uh uh what do you call it
cocaine dealer in l.a colombian guy so i
meet him then he says let's go we go to
the back how much money are you making
i said dude i'm i'm the top sales guy in
my office i'm making 3 500 bucks a month
i'm killing it he starts laughing he
says you're making 3 500 bucks a month
how'd you like to make four grand a week
because you're a pretty big guy i said
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm all in 4 000 a week he
says yeah says here's all i need you to
do i need you to be our muscle and help
us get the money okay from our guys that
haven't paid
he's a matter of fact what are you doing
right now
i said uh nothing it's like one o'clock
in the morning let's go to marina del
rey we got to collect some money he says
but before we do i want you to test the
product so he takes me to the bathroom
he says test the product i do a line
that night
i come out i said
there is no freaking way i can get close
to this thing i thought i was king kong
on steroids i said get this thing yeah
away from this guy right so we went that
night
we collected a hundred thousand dollars
that night with uh this this one guy on
the marina anyways this is like 23 20.
i'm 19 years old 20 years ago
i'm 23 years old you're good no one's
coming after you so we're going guys
going down we go in we got him anyways
we leave we come out
and he says so now you know i don't sell
any memberships i said i i think i kind
of got an idea i'm making 10 or 20 a
week selling this
next week i go to work he says you want
to make another four grand i said no bro
i don't even want the money i stepped
away
here's a moral of the story what i'm
telling you i've been in it i've seen it
i've been around it
every single one of my friends that even
got close to any kind of drugs x special
k
lsd go through craig do any one of them
you want to talk about every single one
of my friends that even got close to
drugs
lost years of their life they lost
momentum
they got fired they lost friendships
they lost girlfriends they lost loved
ones they committed suicide best friends
died because the guy started off with
weed it went to alcohol it went to
cocaine it went to heroin it went to 50
vicodins every day until he died
on may of 2005 and when i got the phone
call i was on a drive to diamond bar and
i have to give a speech that afternoon
it was the most emotional speech
everyone was looking at me saying why
are you saying emotional you guys have
no clue what just happened this guy just
passed away
i didn't want to talk about it but i was
a keynote speaker moral the story
if you have big plans and you want to do
something big
don't even think about getting close to
drugs there was a guy in
canada that we were doing business with
insurance guy this guy was making three
million a year
married
killing it so all of a sudden he gets
invited to all these celebrity parties
in canada but he's a simple guy he was
married to his wife high school
sweetheart everything was good so he
gets invited to these parties
cool parties he starts getting minded to
these cool poker games like oh my gosh
i'm not playing poker with these
hollywood stars with these athletes
well one thing leads to another starts
picking up cocaine everybody runs them
doing drugs he starts doing drugs
he loses his business he loses his wife
he loses his kids six months later he's
homeless in the streets people are
seeing this guy he lost every single
penny his family had his wife at all of
it's wiped out ruined the entire family
just because he got caught up and this
guy is not in his 20s he wasn't in his
thirties he was in his early forties
this [ __ ] can't get you no matter how
old you are yeah they they've gotta be
very very very very very very very good
guys like that like they they see guys
like that a mile away man like he was a
mark like somebody who was setting up
those poker games was like well we're
just gonna get him a couple chicks
around here they all have money though
it wasn't like he was partying with your
money becomes my money that's how i make
my money that's that's that's how that
works but it wasn't even that they saw
him come a mile away yeah but it wasn't
even that it's not when you're around
other money people they're not they're
they're just as big sometimes as idiots
as you are like they're just trying to
recruit more people that want to party
with you they're not trying to steal the
money from you but you want to if you're
putting that t if you're putting that
table together you're putting that risk
together i promise you they're they're
looking for a room
say a guy like that is out there all i'm
saying to you is this was not a playboy
you know how you talk to a guy you know
this guy's his name you you you
interviewed her yeah absolutely come on
you know what i'm trying to tell you is
of course what i'm trying to tell you
this guy was not a player you know how
you talk to a guy around girls like like
i remember when adam said this adam's
like oh gerard and i went out let me
tell you man gerard's pretty good with
the ladies he's pretty calm okay i mean
yeah how long did it take you to realize
the guy's going to be comfortable with
her two days
i was talking to him
but you ever go hang out with a guy and
all of a sudden like dude this guy's
awkward or wrong you ever met a god
that's this guy was the awkward i don't
want to say anything yeah so
you know anybody that's awkward or no so
here's the thing i'll say all right and
this is the truth and this has been my
reality with this because i i've i have
so many friends that have experienced
exactly what you just described man and
i it's a it's an escape from reality so
when you talk to your kids and stuff
like that where you can tell them don't
do drugs don't do this don't do that if
they're broken inside if something's
happened to them where spiritually
they're broken depression's a real thing
i don't know what happened with this guy
maybe he climbed the mountain this is
something i'm seeing that i never would
have expected at this stage in my life
my friends who have kind of like quote
unquote made it they get depressed for
having made it they love the chase they
feel like they have no purpose anymore
that's when they start the partying and
they do all this other [ __ ] i i swear to
god i have no way to
to quantify this
but i thought about this when i was in
the miners i would see guys start doing
stupid things
and i'd be like they're doing this on
purpose because they're giving
themselves an out because it's an
incredibly hard thing to be like i
didn't make it because i just wasn't
good enough that's a hard ass thing to
come to tournaments look in the mirror
and you're talking about that
but now to be able to be like oh man if
i just stopped drinking oh man if i
didn't get hooked on the candy and then
you give yourself that little bit of out
that it wasn't me right and i i swear i
see it now you got guys 40 years old
they're married they've got the mansion
they got but like life is kind of like
it's kind of flatlined for them and they
need to see it destroyed because they
want to see if they can build it back up
again there's something inside of them
that has this self-destructive
compulsion and as far as the kids
you know
you talk about that awkward being
socially anxious you talk about like a
guy who goes to a bar there's a kid who
goes to a bar i can't talk to a girl i
don't have the the confidence unless i'm
drunk unless i'm high right it's a
pretty easy thing to go up to a liquid
courage more than that you go up to a
girl in miami these girls are beautiful
it's hard to you know but it's like hey
i got a bump you want to go to the
bathroom it's like boom break the ice or
we're going we go to a party and it's
like a socially acceptable way to break
that ice and it's that gets the guys
aren't hooked on coke they're not hooked
on whiskey they're not hooked on weed
they're hooked on that culture because
that's how they identify totally being
able to get in you know so like when you
talk to kids and when you have these
conversations it's not about like don't
do it or else it's like dude you have to
figure out a way to be confident in
yourself and take care of your spiritual
and your mental well-being so you're not
susceptible to these things you hit the
nail on the head with the cocaine thing
because i've been there i've seen it
everywhere it's a party drug people it's
a social drug okay you know it's cool
it's sneaky let's go in the bathroom or
whatever
the one thing i will say i
wholeheartedly agree with everything you
said about the drugs the pills the
popping ev you know the the the only
thing that i'll say is with the
marijuana nobody's overdosed on
smoking joints never in the history of
the world oh yeah you know so you have
people that are like
bill maher is a huge wheat advocate he
says vocally i smoke joe rogan i mean
elon musk on his podcast there's people
out there that definitely use the
creative benefits medicinal benefits
there's two different conversations here
the one conversation is should it be
legalized i'm a libertarian you want to
do whatever hell you want to do to your
body do it i'm just telling you it's
going to slow you down i agree with you
if you've got big ambitions if you want
to do something big with your life stay
the hell away from drugs and alcohol
if you have big ambitions you want to do
something big with your life stay the
hell away from drugs and alcohol that's
my feedback i agree now the person can
do whatever they want to do with their
uh their lives that's up to them as my
grandmother would say pat you can't fly
with the eagles in the morning if you're
out with the owls at night oh damn
that's my grandmother what a ground wow
one more time you cannot fly with the
eagles in the morning yeah you were
there was a smack in there with the owls
yeah you can't soar with the eagles in
the morning if you're out with the owls
at night why does your grandma sound
like mike you just need enough cocaine i
think at a certain age everybody because
are you saying owls do cocaine is that
what you're saying
i don't know okay at home prices uh
prices are up in the month of october
but it falls in the month of november so
i'm going to read you both of these
stories first one about is by cnbc
the smb corelogic case shiller 20 city
home and price index out tuesday climbed
18.4 in october from a year earlier the
gain marked a slight declaration from
19.1 year-over-year increase
in september but was about uh in line
with what the economists have been
expecting all 20 cities posted
double-digit annual gains the hottest
market was phoenix up 32.3 wow tampa
28.1 miami 25.7 minneapolis and chicago
smallest increases
chicago and minneapolis smallest
increases anybody surprised 11 and a
half
percent last week mortgage rates fell to
uh 3.05 for the benchmark of 30 years
and fixed rates are 2.66 for 15-year
fixed rate home loans then yahoo story
comes out about november national home
prices fell in november as sales remain
risk although home prices across the
nation remain risk november brought some
relief for buyers as media and sale
prices fell 2.9 percent to 330 the
largest monthly decline since the
beginning of pandemic since the
beginning of the pandemic it dropped
three percent
meanwhile the number of available homes
remains low the number of homes for sale
fell to new loan 14-year history of
report declining 17.7 percent one
product at a smaller home inventory is
that houses aren't staying on the market
for too long the average home sold or
november was on the market for 29 days
that was only the sixth time in history
of the report that the average time on
the market dipped below 30 days tom i'm
going to come to you with this year
first if i'm thinking about if i'm
thinking about buying or selling how
should i think if i'm a buyer how should
i think if i'm a seller what are your
thoughts well hear me now and hear very
clearly you need to get into a house as
soon as you can
in
sensible negotiation of course because
we're heading to be renter nation
translate these three facts number
available homes remains low
stuff that's on the market is on the
market less than 30 days what that means
is anything that comes out there is
selling getting bought up investors are
buying this up corporate investors are
buying it up p e investors are buying it
up because there is a ton of capital out
there uh pat you seem to have mentioned
on a few podcasts that we've printed a
lot of money in the last year yep that
capital is being
lands
you know upstream not downstream with
people it lands upstream at the end of
the day and we're about to become
renter nation because what you see here
is big money is buying up these homes
and
you're going to be renting so if you i
don't know what that means tom so i'm
confused here so you said go buy because
big money's buying up properties and
you're going to be a renter
unpack that for me yeah so if you can't
get into a house soon within your means
within your means you are probably going
to be in a position where you're renting
because these houses are being bought up
there's a lot of corporate buyers out
there there's a lot of p.e
so corporate buyers are buying regular
residential homes not even condos not
even townhouses just homes single fam
matter of fact i read an article this
past week where there was a pe investor
said i think we're in the early innings
um actually
and it was it was a rod's partner a-rod
who said i think we're in the early
innings
of the single family home investment
market where you buy large
consolidations of homes run them through
property management and america becomes
renters of single-family homes not
talking condos not talking apartments
that's where this is going you're saying
this only applies to single-family homes
no this opinion no no what i'm saying is
saying there has always been large
investors that bought large numbers of
mdus multi-multi-dwelling units mfu's
multi-family units now it's coming to
they're buying out neighborhoods of
single-family homes so i i
tell you i've seen this firsthand and i
can't tell you how right he is and this
is the conversation that we've had the
rent is too damn high guy up in new york
this is what happened corporate
corporations came in in new york you're
saying yeah the city yeah bizuto number
one of them all right they come in and
they buy entire blocks
and then what they do is they insulate
themselves from any sort of market
prices so a year ago when everybody said
new york's dead it's leaving everybody's
leaving prices never went down on rent
because these guys can take as many
losses as they can they're selling off
shares they're getting it on both sides
they're selling off shares on what they
own based on the price points
exactly so they sell the shares off and
they're making money then they take
losses off of the off of uh off of what
they earn if the assets underperformed
so they insulate themselves from any
sort of market function you look at
yourself and you say how in the hell is
this still twenty three hundred dollars
for a one bedroom up in jersey city well
because everything's twenty three
hundred dollars they set the market
price and now they're going even as far
as zillow
they have this uh they got sued for a
lot of money i think it's still in court
they were are they they were
artificially raising the prices based on
the corporate entities that own the
prices so you own a house right you
can't sit on the house for two years
you're a normal human being you're like
all right i got to get a good offer and
i got to go live somewhere but if you're
a corporation you can sit on a house for
10 years you hold the asset you use it
as as uh leverage to get other assets
yeah and you and and you just
artificially inflate the price in the
market so what really happens here man
we want to talk about like income
inequality this is where's aoc when it
comes to this [ __ ] where's the democrats
when it comes to this who has access to
credit
credit score is the number one income
inequality in the world it's not
education it's not money it's not salary
it's access to finance who has access to
the money that you need to get this
mortgage correct and the leverage that
you talked about
these these investors they're not paying
3.05 percent they're paying less so the
interest cost that they have to recoup
there when they're renting it to people
is low it's all time
they're taking the money from themselves
correct they're loaning the money out to
themselves yeah here's a question for
you next year's midterms okay during
midterms
do rates go up the rates go down do you
flatline the rates
do you manage because the formula with
inflation is what if inflation is high
how do you control it you raise
increased rates moving down
okay right so inflation at 6.8
do you think we're going to crack seven
percent when the next report comes up
yes okay so let's just say we crack
seven percent a lot of us think we're
already there all right some people are
saying we're at 10 or 11 but let's just
say the numbers come out publicly we
crack seven if we crack seven how
quickly you think the call was made to
powell to raise rates to control
inflation well didn't powell already
announced that he is going to raise
seven times is what goldman sachs is
saying it's gonna be raised next i think
the call is made 30 seconds before they
make the announcement on the inflation
okay so fine if that happens all i want
to know i'm the buyer i'm the seller
rates going up rates going down 2022. am
i a buyer am i a seller what what am i
in 2022 knowing the fact that to control
inflation are going to increase the
rates
i
you got to be a buyer right now you got
to be a buyer if you can be if you've
got the savings and you can get in you
need to be a buyer because i don't think
these assets we may have a bubble where
it pops down like oh 809 yeah but we're
back above that and then some and then
some right so i think you got to be a
buyer within your ways and means
but you got to be
if otherwise because there's an
appreciable asset under that that the
government is going to i mean look at
fannie mae here three percent 2.66
that's very low cost i agree that you
need to be a buyer but where i disagree
is that you have to be within your means
i think that right now if they're giving
out free money like candy and everybody
is using that free money you get yours
too right now if they give if anybody i
know and this goes against everything
that i was brought up believing this
goes against everything that i was
raised this goes against all the
austrian economics that i believe in but
if you have access to credit right now
take it take every single dollar
somebody will give you the free money
train the gravy chain has to come to an
end at some point and even though i
agree with you as long as you can
service it you have to be even at a low
interest rate you have to be able to
every
they want to give you you take because i
guarantee you they are taking it i
guaran out of that stimulus we just did
what three trillion dollars three
trillion what did you get what did you
get america 1200 bucks
you're to pay for every single diamond
at 12. 1200 bucks you're gonna you're
gonna pay for every single diamond of
that stimulus what did you get twelve
hundred dollars
you gotta get yours at this point man
well listen they're getting there i
think you guys are both missing the boat
here as you guys are making blanket
statements i think it's where you're at
in life if you're going to be in the
same city for the next decade and you've
got kids and you want to lock down and
you know you're going to be and you'll
be stability sure buy but if you're like
most of america right now and you're
working from anywhere and you're working
remote you're moving your groove and
your next thing you know you're live in
new jersey now you're in dallas now
you're back in new york now you're back
in in south florida you don't know where
you're going to be the last thing you
freaking need is to lock yourself in the
mortgage because there's something
called house rich cash poor because it's
actually it's this is a fact out there
that a hundred percent of foreclosures
happen when you have a mortgage
so there's a lot of people out there
that
buy a house because they're fed buy a
house american dream you got to buy a
house and they get in the house they're
like holy [ __ ] i didn't realize that i
need furniture for this house and i
didn't realize that i got to pay
maintenance and i got to pay taxes and i
get insurance and i can't afford this
[ __ ] house yeah but pat wrote an
amazing article what what do you do to
write that article
back in 2008 where you're making people
were enabled above their means yeah
exactly and that's what happens in 2008
tell us about that article you wrote
denver post 2012 years ago it was a uh
i think it ended up being a cover story
there you go home buying go go with cold
clear logic and i was renting at the
time yeah and i had a half a million
dollars in a bank and i was still
renting at the time wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
scroll back up we're not going to go
right past those bell bottoms yeah
that's a bell button i'm a bell-bottom
guy what's going on here yeah bell
bottom guy yeah so
full disclosure i'm in a very similar
situation were you married at that point
yet or no oh yeah uh yes okay remember
we have t-call ready okay guys well i'm
in a similar situation where i've got a
lot of cash in the bank and i'm renting
and where have i lived in the last
24 months but adam you're you're a
you're an anomaly okay because you
choose to live this minimalist life at
the age of 40. that's not a very very
common so you're not everybody you're
probably one in a thousand of a person
at your age that's choosing to live like
you you're living below your means
you're a saver you're very you're not a
gucci guy you're not a ferragamo guy
you're not you're not any of those guys
you don't i don't see what a rolex
you're very much of a yeah you're
exactly that the the rich man like
what's the the next millionaire next
door
i read that book it changed my life
exactly who you are so your philosophy
works for a hundred percent of people if
they applied it's going to work for them
my question is more or less of somebody
right now that's sitting there saying
who has the means
who has got money in the bank they got
two three hundred thousand dollars but
they got a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand to put on the down payment and
they can still afford to go out there
and live in that place
should they still wait a year or should
they go pull you know make the decision
to buy a house in 2022 that's what i'm
asking i think what he's saying
the way i see it from his perspective is
the following the people that bought all
of these properties it's like a comp
here's what i mean by comp uh say for
example
hypothetically
a
i don't know let's pick an example of an
insurance company
say aig
is about to buy
40 of his company
for 200 million dollars okay
and his company that is buying for 200
million dollars aig is putting their own
money to buy that 20 uh 40
you get to go on at 2 million okay out
of the 200 million dollars which is what
1 to 200 million right aig is optimistic
they can turn this thing to five billion
dollar company within the next three
years do you think aig is gonna let you
lose your money so you're you're banking
on there's no way they're gonna lose 198
million dollars my 2 million is going to
make money so these private equity guys
are not going to let themselves lose
money so you have to bank on the fact
that they're not doing this
assuming they're going to lose money
they kind of know what they're doing
long term so you hedge that's a good
point you're almost going with them
that's what he's trying to say so and i
think the rent's going to flip right i
think because remember rent rent has to
contain
has to contain marginal value interest
maintenance and the property taxes it
will and so i think the rents are going
to be above ownership costs are you
familiar with something called the the
price to rent ratio
yeah exactly right but you that when you
have the discount when the money is so
cheap the offset there for the tax
deduction on the interest
totally understand so so buying a house
today is cheaper than renting the same
exact course no it depends on what city
you're in well
does something called price to rent
ratio but adam i think that this is this
is the part that that you're right i
think is escaping you is the landlord
shifting well that's the thing once they
own all the property
once you have no option of ownership
they can make the rent whatever they
want
what what are you gonna do they can turn
around tomorrow and they can be like all
right rent's four grand for this one
bedroom it's a form of a monopoly yeah
what what can you do they own their it's
market control so unless you roll down
tyler
which by the way if you own one of those
properties you can do as well keep going
you know one of the best quotes in the
in the sopranos guys the best quote in
the sopranos was you know i don't want
any of that california [ __ ] and the
second best quote is keep going i'll
tell you what buy land aj because god
ain't making any more of it all right
by the way you don't need to even look
at it i'll just tell you what case
studies with families that we're looking
at okay
i got a lot of guys right now that are
looking at buying homes and it ranges
from half a million dollar homes it
ranges all the way up to 10 million
homes the guys are trying to buy right
around me
every single one of them they come back
and they call me rent is 50 higher than
me buying the place
rent
of the same house is 50 higher than
buying the place it's moving guess what
the biggest challenge is with most
people having a down payment right so if
you're buying a community if you if
you're buying a million dollar home do
you have that 20 to put down two hundred
thousand dollars daily boy is going to
be on the podcast for the very first
time nice dylan you're giving us a break
from real estate come here dilly boy hey
what's up big boy how you doing baby
did you guys win
yes you got come around here so people
can't see you come around here
come stand over here dylan
dylan uh uh how about the shin guards
man
no we got the shin guards we finally got
the shin guards yeah we got
though
yeah we finally got the shin guards can
you tell everybody come here for me real
quick come closer to me right
what are four things we do as a family
lead respect proof and love do we bully
people no do we get bullied no what are
four things we pray for
you know
it lead no
no wisdom
wisdom tolerance
understanding
there you go good stuff dilly boy the
best here grab a seat with us grab a
seat with us you can eat your chips
and you can just simply sit there and uh
scan
huh is it chips raccoon awesome all
right so let's continue the next story
that you can sit there and enjoy it with
us but we're going to go to the next
story okay so page number four
tesla owner blows up car after 22
thousand dollar repair quote can you
imagine blowing up a car
after a 22 thousand dollar
uh uh uh repair code this is a daily
wire story tesla owner in finland chose
to blow up the car after receiving a
quote of twenty two thousand six hundred
dollars to fix it when i bought that
tesla the first 923 mile 32 miles were
nice then error code hit the owner said
the video claimed he was approximately
66 pounds of dynamite in the epic
explosion of his 2013 tesla
model s the detonation was filmed in
corey reportedly jalla finland the owner
was told the only way to repair the
vehicle was to replace the entire
battery pack the car originally was sold
for only
57 400 400 this is the video by the way
if you want to make it bigger make the
video a little bit bigger so we can all
see it and let's see what it looks like
when he blows this thing up oh look at
that they're all strong dilly boy watch
this oh boy
this is serious
it's a bit of a light show going on
okay wait for it
holy moly yeah he was not kidding oh boy
holy moly there's parts heading around
so now the question becomes did he make
30 000 of marketing dollars from that
video right there that's the question he
that is a quarry that's a rock quarry so
he found a place
to safely
detonate all right the late tesla what
do you think about that i think kai is
very bored yeah this is in finland but
the
look what's the most you've ever paid
for uh
for repairs maintenance a couple grand
nah not 22 000 that's what i'm saying
what the 20 you get an invoice or a all
right a service service uh invoice for
23 000 dollars the battery pair whatever
the hell it is that's a battery pack how
much is an average battery when you buy
a regular car what's a battery hundred
bucks 200 bucks no this is the battery
pack so this is the entire undercarriage
of the car that's like the engine
essentially it is it is the engineering
exactly how much is an engine for a
regular car
like a four grand three hundred four
thousand dollars max right is that fair
to say two to four thousand dollars
you know what i drive i drive an amg and
10 years old and i love it but i looked
this up you know a full replacement a
full rebuild from people that do this
properly 12.5 to to fix the amg engine
to give me the core of the engine
that's an 80 000 car that's what i'm
pointing and so that's only 12 and this
is 22. so 40 of the price of the car is
the battery so i i want to know how
common this is yeah meaning
i would be blowing i don't know what
kind of psychopath is that much
story for me it's like first of all
you're gonna blow if this guy blew up
the car i guarantee he's got money
because even if it's twenty two thousand
dollars to repair you paid fifty seven
thousand dollars you can probably sell
the car to somebody for thirty thousand
dollars so there's more story to it it's
gotta be a guy that's a business guy
it's got to be a guy that's like can you
just screw the market's going to talk
about it let me just blow this thing up
can you just buy dynamite in finland
like you just buy yeah that's actually a
very good question
i just walked into a bass pro shop and
bought 30 pounds of uh like
give me all your dynamite yeah like it
was attacking me like it was wildly
coyote i was like i'm going i need uh
sticks of dynamite
i got a link here with his bio he is a
software programmer who was reportedly
[Laughter]
uh
sweetie i got like so baked and i did
something really dumb
where's the car he's talking about
baking like a nice cupcake sorry sorry
yeah yeah
okay all right next door dash story
let's go to the door dash story here all
right page three
uh uncle tom is uh very excited today
which is fantastic all right
every door dash employee from engineers
to ceo
will make deliveries this is a cnn story
doordash is asking its employees all the
way up the ranks to its ceo to make a
delivery at least once a month some are
not cheering the news the on-demand food
delivery company new year will reinstate
a program called we dash that it has
paused during the pandemic as a company
grew the founder wanted everyone to
experience different parts of the
product so we could get closer to our
audiences and understand how the product
works a doordash employee comes back
who's making four hundred thousand
dollars to complain about a company-wide
initiative
requiring that he personally make one
delivery a month this is an insider
story
doordash making engineers uh deliver
mandatory we dash starts next year we
need to dash once a month we will be
tracked in performance reviews
what the actual f
i didn't sign up for this
there was nothing in the offer letter
job description about this him
delivering well i mean obviously that
guy right there is a definitely a
believer of doordash and what they do
but what do you think about the story
here how much you want to bet that guy
went to an ivy league school yeah
with you i actually absolutely love this
idea there's nothing worse than a
higher up corporate bureaucrat or
whatever you want to call it who's
completely out of touch
um
i completely agree completely
you know there's to be a man of the
people to understand your product they
use the word specifically closer to our
audience this is exactly the purpose of
why they're actually doing this i assume
though tom so you understand
what it's like to deliver and be a
driver and deal with the traffic and
deal with an angry customer like
to put yourself in the average worker's
shoes how do this one guy who's making
400 grand is too cool for school to do a
delivery a month bro get a life
i completely agree and you know it was
interesting and the first uh company
that got involved with pat he
he evangelized me into it and i thought
it was great and what i did and he knows
this
when i was in uber's in uber i would
talk to the uber driver and i would find
out people that were looking to do a
little bit more looking to do things and
i recruited not one not two but three
that i passed off to agents or at the
company and i thought uber drivers well
yeah but but the point is i ran into
people and uber happened to be the
situation and i said hey check out php
look at the opportunity you could have
here if you're looking for making a
little extra money this is a way to do
it also serving a market so i came to
appreciate at that moment
exactly what every one of our agent does
when they're when they were working with
that of course so i think this is good
to be out on the front i'm a product it
is jaime godina who worked at galpin
ford it's 2002. he sold me a ford focus
stayed up to 11 30 to sell me a ford
focus payment was 228 a month i was so
broke i lost my expedition i couldn't
pay the payments anymore i'm at the
lowest point of my life in o2
years later i said when i was sitting
with them he told me i said what what
what what car should i buy
he says well uh
what do you want to get i said what do
you have he said great question let me
show you the cars that i have i have
this i have this i have this it was all
ford products
i love the fact that a guy who owns the
product is selling it to me i i have a
hard time if you're selling mercedes
you're driving a bmw yeah like when eli
manning was doing the commercials for
toyota corolla and i was like get out of
here
that's right he hops
hops in the g wagon goes home yeah so so
the point is they're gonna drive the
toyota to my g wagon there's a part of
this that i like and guess what this
does the guy who's running doordash just
realized who doesn't really believe in
the concept of what they do as a company
and who's too much of a high you know
corporate executive that's not going to
get their hands too dirty to go out
there and say you know what maybe this
is what i gotta do to understand what
everybody else does it helps you get
closer to your uh to the folks that are
also working my question is who would
think this is a bad idea other than this
engineer who probably just wants to sit
in front of a computer all day maybe
he's baked or not cookies of course
why would why is this a bad idea play
devil's advocate here this is not about
it it's a bad idea exactly i can't even
think about it by the way what i'm
saying i can't even think of it there
are many companies that do it already
but i tell you i've been in many
meetings where you launched an
initiative and all of a sudden you know
who's in and who's not right it's a
filtering process and i love the fact
that doordash announced this they push a
little hard it'll open up go a little
lower and push it hard it'll open up a
little lower there you go let me tell
you man that this actually annoys me so
much like i don't even want to use door
dash like this one guy being too good
for it but but don't let that happen
because the ceo is doing the right i
look at it the opposite way i actually
this is on my
actually radar more respect for your
dash now totally i like the fact that
the ceo and the founder thought about
this idea like think about it this way
we were talking about the nhl yesterday
right
and hl just announced that they will not
be sending
their players to the olympics nhl uh the
players uh union agreed to it they just
said we're not sending players to the
olympics this is an ap news right
commissioner gary bayton made me made
the announcement wednesday making it
official what seemed inevitable in
recent days when a rash of positive copy
19 test results caused several teams to
shut down the list of postponed games
balloon 250 give the profound disruption
to the nhl's regular season schedule
caused by recent covert related events
olympic participation is no longer
feasible bateman said the league will
use the previously scheduled february
6th through 20 seconds olympic break to
make up those games and others that need
to be rescheduled okay great here's the
guy that makes a decision saying we're
not going there so who's going to be
playing just lower level people going to
be playing for
i like when sometimes decisions are made
from the top
you hear who complains you hear who
doesn't complain and you move with the
people that are supportive of the
decision that's being made i support
doors i have a question is that just
americans or is that any nhl players
that means canadians scandinavians
russia everyone's affected so you're
telling me that vladimir putin is just
going to go around if it's these pests
exactly yeah so i don't know if this is
going to work it's okay it's going to
work you think so if you play in the nhl
is vladimir putin going to pay players
7.8 million dollars a year yeah maybe if
you uh disagree with putin maybe you
don't have legacy in russia though you
live in canada
you have no problem putting your skates
on if you have no feet i think they're
going to be okay
fauci says u.s should consider vaccine
mandates for domestic air travel but
doesn't expect it now
you know one thing about him don't don't
you feel a warm fuzzy feeling every time
he gets on tv he's always right like you
know it's just
everything he says there's something
about him that's just very warm and
fuzzy this is a cnbc story when you make
vaccinations a requirement that's
another incentive to get more people
vaccinated if you want to do
that with domestic flights i think
that's something that we should
seriously consider there's no indication
at this point that a vaccine mandate is
on its way for u.s flights when asked
found she declined to say
whatever he has made the recommendation
to president biden already u.s
passengers were masked to
board planes and keep them on the
duration of the flight except when
eating or drinking international
travelers must also show proof of
vaccination and a negative covet test in
order to board on a u.s bound flight and
also wear a mask so
do you think i had i had the uh alan
dershowitz on and i had kenta heckin
lively on both of them wrote a book that
came out on october 26th one of the
books was titled the case against
vaccine mandate the other one was titled
the case for who
who was against alan dershowitz for kent
is against and i asked alan the
following question which is a little bit
disturbing
i said alan all this stuff that's going
on right now in
australia he says what's going on in
australia i said alan you mean to tell
me you're not following he says no i'm
following it but i want to know which
part of australia you're talking about i
said well in australia if you don't take
the vaccine you can't work you can't
make income you have to stay home you
can't get out you can't do nothing right
that's what australia is doing i said
how different is us's constitution
versus australia's constitution meaning
can if if if australia's constitution
doesn't protect the minority from the
majority is the minority in america
protected from the majority with the
constitution the way it's written he
said if america wanted to do the same
thing that australia is doing they can
do it as well the constitution permits
us to do exactly what
australia did and fyi do you know what
this guy taught at harvard law for 50
years constitutional law do you know who
a student was soto but
so
barack obama was one of his students so
if if fauci is saying something like
this they will rarely say something like
this
they're preparing you to say brace for
impact in the next two to four months
this may be coming your way
i i wholeheartedly disagree with why
i don't think domestic i don't think
where any of us are going to agree with
domestic mandates but do you think it's
coming though i don't think it's coming
okay i don't i mean i think we've we've
in my opinion we've dealt with the worst
of the pandemic already i've had this
this is one of the biggest cases we've
ever had yeah but it's the weakest
variant they say that it's it's it it's
uh it's going around like texas just
went to work
texas just went to code red but here's
my question do you think
international flights to come in the
united states which are i i assume
happening right now that you need to
have vaccine mandates for international
travel if you go to canada you do
if you go say it again canada requires
proof okay i'm saying no to fly into the
united states don't you need to have
proof of vaccination from any country or
other in the world
or a negative covenant you're saying
that they're coming in to come in
exactly international travel i don't
know i think it's negative oh yeah i
don't think it is
okay gotcha it's one of the other tyler
look it up you need to have vaccinated
or negative tests when i came back from
uh the vacation in mexico that you need
either a negative cova test pcr or your
vaccination so here's
the pcr tests they just the cdc just
basically came out and said yesterday
throw the pcr test away they can be they
could be positive up to 12 to 16 weeks
after you're no longer well no it says
here in the article international
travelers must also show proof of
vaccination
and a negative cova test in order to
board a u.s bound flight and also by the
way here you go so david this is this is
this is coming from the embassy
last updated december 17 2021 all
non-immigrant yo david you're a
non-immigrant right or you're not you're
all non-immigrant
u.s there you go so
non-us citizen
air travelers to the united states will
be required to be fully vaccinated and
to provide proof of vaccinations that is
prior to
boarding an airplane to the united
states and you're not a citizen you have
to be back do you agree with that
not at all my aunt just came from
colombia she didn't have to show any
proof of vaccination was it before
december 17th yeah she's come that's one
side before oh no i mean she came uh
she's been here she's still here when
did she come to jail she came uh this
year no no this is december
seven days ago this is ten days ago they
just changed it ten days ago are we
gonna talk about that's what i'm saying
this is just ten days ago the two
million people or two and a half million
people that have crossed the southern
border that don't have to be vaccinated
that don't have to have a mask that
nobody actually gives a [ __ ] about you
could just walk across the border and be
you could have ebola
that's a complete difference you're
asking dangerous questions
you're asking dangerous questions but go
back to this you guys still haven't
answered my question here do you think
in the next two to four weeks eight
weeks we're going to get to a point
where fatch is going to get up and say
you have to have a personal vaccination
proof vaccine to travel domestically i
don't what do you think gerard no i
think i think this is i think this is a
a dog whistle letting you know that it's
coming that's what i think this is i
think this is
you know just letting you know it's
coming and it's weird because it's
coming out of both sides of the mouth
right on this side i think they're
prepping us for it on the the air travel
side and then yesterday we said we're
going to go from 10 days to 5 days
because we're concerned about the
economy we're concerned about too many
people being you know on that we could
actually bring the economy to a
standstill you saw that that's what he
said
if we have all these people on a variant
that's not so severe but required on a
10-day uh quarantine so on one hand he's
worried about the economy on the other
hand he's not worried about the uh the
economics of the the airlines and he's
saying we're going to do this but i
think it's coming and i think they're a
little bit on both sides of their mouth
and scientifically why does he still
have a job
why is he still not [ __ ] the
scientific inconsistency in this is
pretty shocking but what i'm trying to
say because why is he not they're
they're into somebody else saying yeah
they're in too deep and that's an
admission that that they lost control of
it at this point if if they fire him
because they went so far by they deified
this guy well i i don't i don't know
about that because let me let me tell
you the
the democrats can spin it all they want
and say we never brought him in the
first place anyway somebody else did
it's just time to have him you know how
long he's been in that position as the
the nine years
reagan did you see this reagan did with
fouchy yeah jimmy kimmel did everything
but get on his knees and gargle for this
guy on
tv
so
we're talking about listening
jimmy kimmel does it either way i don't
really care here's the thing oh my god
yeah listen i would have agreed with you
guys a week ago i don't agree anymore
because the last two days they have
dumped so much
on cdc re their their read you can see
the spin machine coming and they're
doing it right now during a dead news
time they're doing it when everybody's
that is wearing this weird kind of like
sure the nation's on vacation right now
we've got that weird time between
christmas and new year's and they're uh
loosening the restrictions they're
loosening the mandates they're uh it
came out i believe it was pfizer and
modern now have myocarditis for kids uh
they have a um
what's it called a warning on them now
well this was completely safe for kids
now it has a warning so they're they're
trying to come to reason and then the
spin is going to be oh we were always
the reasonable people because right now
even with the entire cia behind them
there's so many people are going to vote
against them in the midterms that they
can't they can't cover there's not
enough dead people in chicago to cover
their losses right now right so i think
what's happening right now is a massive
pivot towards and let's just be honest
right you can disagree with me all you
want adam but democrats love kovid they
love it they'll never admit it but they
love it coveted got rid of the orange
man covid gave them complete and total
control cove that coveted gave them the
the key to the castle it gave them the
opportunity to completely when you say
democrats you're talking politicians or
people
it's hard for the great because i don't
know anybody very anybody republican
democrat moderate liberal that was so
specifically talking about you i was
talking nobody loves kovacs i disagree
and this is why if you're talking about
politicians
okay maybe we'll go there
no i don't know any democrats that are
like brah
love that cover dog i love
by the way by the way but there's a part
of him i agree but it's not everybody so
i don't put you in the democratic uh uh
community that he's talking about okay
the other day on the flight you guys saw
that video with the ladies punching the
guy in the face
and then the same footage playboy model
former playboy model and she was in
baywatch excuse me raider nation
cheerleader let me just add that you
shouldn't add that because that's an
embarrassment to anybody that's a great
game you should have kept that well
covered in it
some kind of real pride to raider nation
in a minute here with john madden but it
is what it is the raider nation will
forgive you tom it's headlines it's
everywhere i'm giving
check this out check this out so this
girl gets on the fly have you seen this
video or no i heard i saw a headline i
didn't see the actual video can you pull
up the video the lady so she gets on the
flight she keeps telling this guy put
your mask on tell him to put his mask on
put your mask on her mask is down she's
telling this other guy to put his mask
on what and then she says she says take
your hands off me and she calls him
something and says shut up
and then next thing you know just pull
up the video on twitter right there you
played the video you can play it she
punches the guy in the face and spits in
his face unfortunately this is a former
uh if you go on twitter you'll find a
video a lot sooner than the way you're
trying to the guy was 80 years old just
go on twitter yeah because something 80
year old man what yeah he was 80 years
old okay uh he was 80 years old click on
that i don't know why not click on it
click on it there you go
uh uh there should be
uh go go to go back to twitter
okay don't you just have time is
undefeated man yeah so anyway so he she
punches him in the face you can't find
it
she punches she has her mask down no no
she has her mask down they love it put
your damn mask on they love it adam yeah
brother but i don't like they love new
york
brooklyn
okay francisco i don't know what's going
on in new york but i don't know anybody
republican or democrat that quote
unquote loves covet they love it i don't
know what that even means they love it
they love they're they're they're in you
know if al davis was still alive he
would have said wait a second how fast
is she can she play the corner
that's the raider way right there
i like this springs
tyler can't get it so anyway she she
spider it's all over the place i don't
know how you think they'll never admit
it adam they'll never admit it but who's
the deep
dark
crevices of their cold progressive heart
there are people that do you're saying
like aoc democrats progressive rasheeda
television i don't know
what are you talking about
small businesses they hate small
businesses here it is right here by the
way
okay you put a volume bigger
entertainment tyler make it bigger and
then go fast forward to like 30 seconds
because you're gonna have to wait a long
time we need john madden
so here she is boom
look she says put your mask on
punch him in the face
good i hope she does go to jail
a little scratch there you see the claws
positive
but there are people who like the fact
that they can use this as a way to tell
you what to do but she doesn't even have
a mask on but that's not like i've seen
hypocrisy before but this is just an
insane level of democracy she's not
alone be honest with you she's quite
there's quite a few people like that out
there again i'm talking about the
democrats but it's because it's them bro
like and you don't have to how do you
know she's a democrat though
i'm just saying how do you know i'm
willing to make a significant i've never
seen a republican that passionate about
someone putting on their match
that's coming from a democracy
[Laughter]
all right anyway so uh going back to it
does she go to jail though uh uh when
one's gonna handle her out she looks
like that's some good panther if you
continue with the video the lady keeps
recording cops came and took her i don't
know where she went afterwards i'll be
honest just just to go forward with it
again david real quick yeah dude the
french laundry these guys put all of
california on lockdown and then they're
out eating with each other shoulder to
shoulder at a thousand dollars do as i
say they don't do it nonstop this marie
antoinette [ __ ] is non-stop yeah when
you're right you're right that's right
psychopath [ __ ]
it's fine
this leads to so so again now you have
to realize to me
if you
make
any more bad decisions between now and
midterms everybody knows it's not going
to be pretty
but tom if let's just say they flip 70
seeds 80 seeds if it's a blood bath of
all time you got to figure out a way to
not make it the blood bath of all time
that's embarrassing it's so bad that
this story comes out folks just
yesterday
on uh what's taking place where's that
story at in regards to people retiring
where's that story
uh okay there's a page of five go on
page five okay so this story is
absolutely
mind-boggling on what the story is surge
in house democratic 2022 retirement
announces as 2021
comes to a close a trio of democrats and
a house representative representative
stephanie murphy of florida lucille roy
uh royal roy uh ballard of california
albio cedars of jersey last week said
that they'll retire at the end of the
year
rather than run again in 2022 midterms
for another term in congress the latest
news brought 23 to the number of house
democrats who are retiring or bidding
for another office rather than run for
reelection in 2022
with when their party tries to defend
its razor thin majority in the house the
gop needs to net gain of just five seats
in the 435 member chamber next year to
regain house majority loss to democrats
in 2018 midterms republicans have
history on the side on the average party
that wins the white house in a
presidential election loses more than 25
seats
in the ensuing midterm election how ugly
you think it's going to get to the point
where guys are retiring well i think
there's three things going on here thing
number one is they know what you're
about to say pout or what i think you're
about to say is correct
right now look history's not on your
side midterm is usually tough for the
party in the white house okay we have to
contain our losses point number one but
point number two is we have so much
going on social there's not this isn't
just a a controversy
you know like with monica lewinsky or
something this is a nationwide
multi-year pandemic that's hitting the
economy and now the wave is pushing back
against the administration so the
administration has got that going on and
then the third thing that's going on is
this is also historical right now you've
got a lot more republican governors and
what is happening in the states is all
the redistricting which is why we've got
these districts that look so freaking
weird the way they're set and so you
have redistricting some might call that
gerrymandering yeah it is for
republicans or democrats it's
gerrymandering and so right now you've
got a lot of folks that are feeling like
their
alternate party uh governor is
gerrymandering them out of a seat that
even if we didn't have all the covet and
all the national pandemic and everything
that goes with it right now there's a
whole bunch of people that are being
gerrymandered right out of a seat so and
this is a trick that both sides use but
there happens to be more republican
governors right now and so i think they
got to contain
they have to contain contain and when
these folks can announce retirement
early they can at least get maybe
something of a candidate up that's what
i think's going on yeah well they're
also you know when when red landing
happens man
the far left in the party is where all
the money is that's where everything's
coming from and they're primary in their
own people so there's a people people
don't realize there's a civil war within
the democratic party right now all right
and the progressives have won the
progressives have hijacked nancy pelosi
because that's where the money is and
people like aoc we talk about a lot
because she's a fire brand and all she's
she's not a very powerful person in in
in terms of what she can actually
accomplish as a legislate as a
legislator but she's an incredibly
powerful person with her voice her
ability to raise funds her turn my aoc
yeah i'm sorry are you telling me aoc
yeah so what they do what the quote
unquote squad does what justice
democrats do it's justice democrats if
you guys want to look it up on twitter
if you want to know what nancy pelosi is
going to say tomorrow follow justice
democrats today they're think tank and
they're they're probably the most
powerful lobby in the world right now so
psychotic chakra body is the most
powerful man in america that nobody
knows whose name is it's like a chatty
cathy doll you pull the string on those
democrats and nancy plays a very
dangerous human being so what happens is
that they don't run in purple districts
they don't put progressives up in purple
districts they don't go after
republicans they go after democrats they
hollow out their own base they go after
heavy blue areas and then they run to
the left of that and that's what you're
seeing well you know the new new york
governor probably why cuomo was ousted
was because he was for all intents and
purposes of moderate in today's world
and they wanted far left push hard left
push wanted to get on board
i got rid of him so when you're looking
at what's happening right now you're
going to see the left double down and
triple down because they're going to
lose in the midterms and you're going to
have i guarantee you mark this right now
an hour and a half into this podcast aoc
is going to grandstand and say
they didn't ask us to help they didn't
ask us to fundraise they didn't ask us
to come in and she's going to blame the
bloodbath on the fact that they tried to
appeal to the moderate voter instead of
rally the left base
she wants to win on the fringe she's not
here for america she's here for the
revolution and that's what's happening
right now within that side that's where
the money's going yeah but okay so let's
just say that's the case fine you want a
different angle the angle i'm going
right now is
are they going to be even more extreme
between now and midterm so you said i
don't think they're going to make uh
woody color domestic travel mandatory to
be
shown your vaccination card here's what
i will tell you i think it's a bad move
if they do i think it's going to hurt
them even more at midterms if they do i
think the smarter was not to do it i
agree i agree with that but by the way
here's the part if they're strategic
don't do it if they do it they're going
to piss off a lot of regular people that
their job realizes me off like i'm not
even double vaccinated you know i would
be like dude yeah exactly let me ask you
this yeah can the republicans keep
donald trump shut up long enough to win
the midterms like they need to win
yes can they keep him bottled up
are you saying to win the midterms no
they're going to win the midterms yeah a
greatly thing that's going to rally the
left to come back out is orange man
everything that's happened is orange man
bad of course everything over the last
six years that's happened in this the
only reason joe biden is the president
is because the orange man brain drain
well let me let me read that since
you're saying
let me let me read that since you're
saying that because
this this takes it to uh a story that
came out with trump and mcconnell right
let's go into that story because it's
appropriate with what you just said 52
percent of republicans
disapprove of mitch mcconnell
as trump ramps up his pressure campaign
to topple people this is an insider
story a new gallup poll found that 52
republicans disapprove the job of mitch
mcconnell was doing a senate majority
leader as former president donald trump
continue to call for the kentucky
republican ouster meanwhile 46 percent
of republicans say they approved of
mcconnell a dismal approval rating in
comparison to 71 approval waiting by the
same group for his counterpart in the
other chamber house minority leader
kevin mccarthy frequently referred
mcconnell as the old crow trump has
criticized the kentucky republican for
not sufficiently indulging his claim of
a stolen 2020 election for helping to
pass a bipartisan infrastructure bill
and for cutting deals with democrats to
raise the debt ceiling he continues
to say you're asking a question is going
to stay out of it or not
trump says he'll endorse alaskan
governor mike dunleavy for re-election
as long as don libby doesn't back gop
senator lisa murkowski's re-election
campaign former president trump's
praised the the the
president the governor don levy that's
running complete and total endorsement
this endorsement is subject to his
non-endorsement
of senator lisa murkowski who has been
very bad for alaska including losing
anwar perhaps the most important
drilling site in the world and much else
murkowski was one of the seven gop
senators who voted to convict
trump in his february impeachment trial
should donald be failed to meet the
conditions trump endorsement would be
null and void and of no further force or
effect the former president said so what
do what does this mean
uh uh story came out yesterday saying if
trump uh lindsey graham said if trump
wants to be the nominee he can just say
today and he's a nominee lindsey graham
quoted yesterday's scene if trump wants
to just come out and say he's going to
be the nominee he's already nobody's
shocked that to use gerard's term
lindsey graham is gargling on uh
trump's yeah but but orange man i don't
know i don't think that was gargling i
think he's making a clear point but the
point is listen you guys are infatuated
with this gargling stuff i don't know
what's going on with you guys we just
want our breath to smoke
what are you doing for new year's eve go
have some fun for new year's eve
soho house is a membership and it's
expensive i know if you know that or not
i wanted to kind of bring that up uh but
here's the
point he has so much influence today
that he's poking everywhere he's a king
maker he's he but he is a king maker but
at the same time he's not sitting
sitting on the sidelines so here's a
question here's a question
say
republicans
say they want to replace mcconnell who's
the who's who's another person that
could be
someone that could give a fight for his
money to be that because this is about
to flip here in a minute
rand paul
yeah they're two of the most hated guys
no do not put rand paul on ted cruz hate
ability scale well no wait a minute
there's mackay
and ted cruz on like the least liked
people in the world i put randy and then
rand paul what i mean i said by the left
rand paul are you kidding me have you
seen what he's done to fouchy literally
try to kill him twice i don't think
people hate rand paul as much as ted i'm
saying the left
i agree i'm saying they still don't hate
rand paul as much as ted cruz uh yeah
ted cruz is one of the least i've never
listened to any of the hearings yes i
have and with that nobody likes ted cruz
ted's crew's parents don't like him this
is but this is exactly what his face
doesn't like
this is exactly you know who hates ted
cruz as beto o'rourke hayes ted cruz
yeah the uh trump called his wife ugly
and disgusting and he's like you got my
vote trump i mean nobody likes ted cruz
yeah that was uh before he had the beard
now he's now he's tough ted yeah
in cancun
the uh look this is exactly what i just
said aoc is doing this is bad for
american politics the polarization
working towards the fringes it used to
be you had to win the center to win yeah
now it's working towards the fringes is
where the money and the volunteers are
and it's it's again we're just in this
constant cycle of of this pendulum this
this again dialectic of getting further
and further and further away to the edge
somebody said jim jordan by the way what
do you think about jim jordan
by the way mitch mcconnell trey gowdy
bring back
mitch mcconnell's horrible mcconnell
mitch mcconnell is awful mitch mcconnell
is in the dick cheney george bush he's a
globalist he is part of this again my
issue with the democratic party this
modern this modern incarnation of the
democratic party we talked about this
with matt zeller is they don't give a
[ __ ] about the american citizen they are
all about their international buddies
they are they are representing the
international community they are impris
they are representing global interests
not us
that's my issue with them
and that's my issue with mitch mcconnell
as well mitch mcconnell doesn't give a
[ __ ] about kentucky
mitch mcconnell cares about his standing
on the worldwide stage
and the more politicians that we have
that we elect that represent global
interests instead of their constituency
the worse this is going to get
so i mean that's that for all of his all
of his evils for all the things that you
don't like
donald trump
he never once
appeared to care about global interests
over the american citizen that he tried
to disband nato i mean he tried to break
break up global alliances something to
be said was
try to disband nato we try to get france
to pay their freaking bills exactly
quick fight with he picked fights with
our allies
whether that's a good thing or bad thing
we can debate no no but he did that but
again we have but i can't let you frame
it in that way we can we can't allow it
to be framed that way
having somebody pay
what they're contracted to pay is not
the same as picking a fight if i owe you
ten thousand dollars and you come to me
and you're like gee where's my money and
i'll be like whoa adam let's not pick a
fight that's not picking a fight that's
hey
pay up [ __ ] you pay me pay me
again
whether that was right or wrong he still
did pick a fight with i mean he cozy to
dictators excuse me excuse me the
dictators close they'd rather hang out
with putin and
excuse me mrs merkel
rather than getting along with miracles
what was the mob movie where the guy
comes out i think it was joe pesci comes
up to him was like you know yeah i got a
i got a thousand dollar bill
whoa
you want me to pay this bill
you're embarrassing me in front of all
my friends how dare you embarrass me
like this that's what you're talking
about that's how democrats act like how
dare you embarrass friends make them pay
their bill oh god we we're we're wealthy
we'll pay it screw you macron pay up
pay him how should he have handled it
what do you mean how should he have
handled i i liked that about trump i
liked that he didn't you know
kowtow to the global interests i like
that about him what i didn't like about
him is that he picked fights with people
he didn't need to pick fights with and
he pissed off people he didn't need to
piss off the guy wanted all the smoke
all the time yeah didn't need that but
having somebody that actually for the
first time in in years
seemed like they cared about the
american citizen and not the global
interests was very appealing well in my
opinion i think he would have had a lot
more people on his side if he would have
explained how you would explained it hey
listen guys
i'm here for america and what's
happening
is these guys have a contract to pay two
percent of their gdp but he did not well
pat but no no but he did execute
how much how much of it america was
paying exactly they were showing i
remember that i remember that so listen
if somebody said he should have sold
that better well let me let me tell you
rather than let me tell you why he
couldn't okay yeah and i i agree with
you but this is also what needs to be
understood about the moment
who owns the new york times who owns
this you're saying the media wouldn't
cover the media covered him left and
right that's what i'm saying but he can
cover the words that are coming out of
his mouth if you want to send those
words god you're so close adam you're so
close just one more step who owns the
media
well obviously the libs but
and they you're gonna go china with this
where are you going with this
global community
so if the global community owns the tech
giants and owns the media giants and
trump is going after the money of the
global community
how do you think the global community
who owns those those
information disseminators are going to
present that information he's going
after our peeps you need to write
something baby that's it yeah people i'm
talking about tv i'm not talking about
articles most people aren't reading the
new york times or the wall street
journal the washington post or any of
these outlets they're just watching tv
whether it's cnn or fox msnbc
if if they just trump goes live sure on
if trump went live they'd cover on every
network he's not biased he's going live
but with abc nbc cnn fox news and he can
still say those words people could see
it and if he would explain himself
rationally he would have had a bet he
would have more people in his corner
okay but i don't i don't disagree with
that
adam i don't dispute that but you you
just ran into a generality from a
specific the specific is is that he did
explain that he was going to nato to
established countries like france and
germany and he was going to ask them to
pay their fair share of freaking person
missiles that we put in their backyard
to protect their ass from russia back in
the day and now so he's saying i need
you to pick up the tab for this and you
are a western nation with a thriving
economy and the means to pay and our
taxpayers even though there's a benefit
to keeping russia on the defensive
shouldn't be paying it for you if we
elect you know aid missions and go
around the world for other things yeah
then we're going to do that but i want
you to pay your bill and adam on this
specifically it was explained it's just
there's a lot of people out there
specifically in the global media that
didn't want to hear this here's here's
how you gotta look at it adam the
average person goes like this
average person goes like this average
person looks at trump and they're like
oh oh what he's saying this makes sense
hey mom cnn msnbc is he right
is he right
no he's not right it's not fair to give
one of our allies like friends
such pressures to have to pay their debt
they're going such troubles right now
what about the families and they're like
what a greedy bastard do you want to
make that's how this thing works i don't
know if those kind of conversations like
okay maybe but i think some people can
join me not everybody's watching the tv
with their mom
they're looking at that saying what are
they doing
you're making an analogy there i thought
they were literally asking me dude i
agree with that so much because i've
actually tried to like rationalize what
happened in my mind and the closest like
analogy that i could come up with is
like hillary clinton and every karen in
the world they divorced america they
were like i'm done with this [ __ ]
there's nothing you ever met a woman
going through a divorce there is nothing
that ex-husband can do he ain't [ __ ]
there's nothing that dude can do he's a
deadbeat he's this he's that there's
nothing he can say there's no jokes that
are funny there's no food that tastes
good when they are done with you they
are done with you and listen liberal
white women call it what it is liberal
white women divorced america
divorced it divorced donald trump they
divorced america when america chose
donald trump they said i'm done burn
this place to the ground give me my pink
hat i'm a-going marching and that's it
they were done with it there was nothing
that man could have done where they
would have given him any sort of credit
whatsoever
we reached the he ain't [ __ ] moment of
the divorce we're talking about nato
right now on allies right is that where
no not you but this general discussion
yeah
no no that's what we were talking about
paying your fair share it led to you
claiming that he was divisive with
uh
allies and then he brought up saying the
fact that it was towards france because
france wasn't willing to pay their fair
share they were expecting other
countries they expected america to pay
for it
do i agree with what you're saying yes
let me just throw something back at you
just for food for thought is donald
trump a brilliant marketer
yeah i think he is i agree yes
did he not come up with simple
catchphrases to prove his point like
hope and change not about that but build
out build them up
build the wall
i didn't actually find that that funny
that was good
um
i build the wall i believe lock her up
what else
drain the swamp three words
you're telling me he couldn't have come
up with make nato pay
people have been like oh i can't like i
can't tell you
that wouldn't have been a bad [ __ ]
idea donald trump jr we know you're
listening right now adam sass is
available
nato pay t-shirt ready yeah i will wear
[Music]
something like that pay up frenchy
rather than going on and
by the way tyler can you put that up
please can you put that up real quickly
this is why this is why
currently the most trending the most and
i'm talking about the highest of the
most trending merge we're selling today
for all of valuetainment is this right
here
jason gibson tweeted.christmas is here
thank you bye damon he didn't just order
one color he got the white the black the
hats the valuetainment let's go adam
yeah if you don't by the way even adam
wears his shirt let's go live where's my
cup
i was rocking this i was rocking down
hey if you're on put the link below to
going and ordering the shirt let's go
adam it's your pay up frenchies next
night
you know what we need
he's a brilliant marketing guy whether
you like him or not i want to get two
more stories time's up put the time up
david let me go to the next door cdc
shorten this cover 19 isolation
recommendation to five days for
asymptomatic people after some disease
experts said ten days was way too long
go to page five tom i think you got
something to say about this i'd like to
go through two other stories after this
it was a steadfast rule for most of the
pandemic people with kobe 19 were
isolating for 10 days
or they were asymptomatic for 10 days
for the first positive covenanting test
but the cdc altered the recommendation
on monday amid a steep rise in omicron
cases across u.s people with cover 19
who don't have symptoms should isolate
for just five days
then wear a mask around others for
another five days the cdc said his
decision was motivated by the
understanding that most chronovirus
transmission occurs early in the course
of illness generally between one and two
days before symptoms arrive in two to
three days after a person becomes
symptomatic tom
i did this is just
they're just moving the
they're moving the goal line here to to
benefit themselves because you could
just translate what everything that she
said to
we are very worried about the economy oh
wait i meant the midterms and it goes
back to what we were talking about
before this is they're they're just
they're manipulating this for the
benefit of the economy because
they do see that if a bunch of people
with moderate symptoms on a strain that
doesn't appear to be as intense and i
would know something about this
um is now we can move it down to five
days because we don't want to bring the
economy to a halt because now they need
to care about the economy yeah this is
garbage trash politics 101
if they keep going the way that they're
going everybody who gets
like pat said earlier if you get
infringed upon that's a vote i'm done
i'm done one more thing i'm just done
with these people so what do they do
instead they can't admit that they've
lost the war on covid they can't admit
that this thing
they've lost all credibility so what
they're going to do now is the same
thing what what a new administration
does when they come into a city and they
quote unquote clean up crime how many
covet cases we've got about can you go
up to covet cases finger date well
here's the thing you can send me the
cases you clean up crime by saying oh
instead of petty theft being if you
steal up to a thousand it's if you steal
up to ten thousand so petty theft is
down one hundred percent yeah it's not
people are still stealing a thousand
dollars worth of stuff you move the goal
line to ten thousand now they want to
take a victory lap watch in a month
they'll be taking a victory lap that
there's no covert cases right but all
they did is just change the guy by the
way and if the other party is in charge
from
watch this year this is cases
all time
trump
goes till whatever the date is january
26th i go to january 6th and then it
drops and then spike
not just any kind of a spike a massive
spike now go to death
go to uh it's the top left instead of
instead of clicking new cases
watch this
watch this what this looks like okay
up up down
cases are high
that's having caught up which means the
percentage
is lower
than what it was with a year ago but
it's still a spike on where they're at
right now so
okay all good let's go so you think tom
this is a can you make you've got
comments i just have a question yeah
i'll go for it what i want some
manipulation
what i want right now
are solutions meaning
none of us have medical degrees we can
complain on how much we hate fouchy in
cases and gov
i think
we all have strong opinions what's your
solution to what's happening right now
solution-oriented
when the democrats lost lebron that's
when everything changed i really believe
that when lebron sent out that tweet of
spider-man pointing at spider-man
pointing at spider-man where it was
covered cold flu that sent shock waves
through everybody again what's the
solution our profit if we lost our
profit then we've lost everybody and
they pivoted immediately i really
believe that was the impetus for the
paycheck so what's your solution i
called that two months ago it's not i
said lebron is going to change the game
on covet and china
watch in the next six to 12 months
lebron also tweet something about china
that's against china six to twelve
months watch why watch
just watch you called it it called that
lap
in 2020 it happens 2022
can you give me some solutions here can
we get a solution
it goes away
it goes away we live our lives what goes
like well it goes we live on talking
about
you're talking about the solution for
this just in general
it's real people are getting it you made
a comment you made a sarcastic comment
and you said
none of us here are doctors okay i
didn't say i didn't mean it like
sarcastic but i meant like what's up
it's i don't know what else to say to
you i'll say with a mexican accent
yeah so do you know who robert w malone
is doctor robbie
so he he is the one that invented the
mrna technology okay he came out with
the technology yeah and and he
has called out against his own invention
saying this is
not
you know it's not good he is
fighting and arguing against it the guy
had 511 000 followers his account got
suspended he's on joe rogan today okay
so here's the thing small little podcast
when
yeah i don't know if you've heard of the
guy he's a pretty solid yeah yeah so joe
is going to have them on today spotify
is kicking ass shout out to spotify fyi
everybody that wondered if it was a good
move to go to spotify joe rogan was
right to go to spotify and kudos to
spotify for saying we don't give a [ __ ]
we just want eyeballs they're
capitalists phenomenal gotta love it
hopefully the leadership doesn't change
by the way with the direction they're
going here's the point you said well
we're not really doctors and experts
you know we're not saying
that's the tone i felt i felt that tone
we're not really doing you want me to
say to you in spanish
the point i'm trying to make to you is
the point i'm trying to make dudes even
doctors who are experts cannot even
voice their opinions today that's the
problem the problem is fauci only goes
on podcasts and channels that are asking
questions that he agrees with the only
person go to your guy dr mike whatever
the guy name was doctor mike pre-code my
guy now okay he was your neighbor is
what i'm trying to say pre-covet the guy
had 34 million subscribers you know how
many subscribers got on youtube 10 11
million you know why because on the home
page it was always dr mike dr mike dr
mike and guess what dr mike did after we
did the interview with judy mykovitz
dr mike gets up there and says she has
no clue what she's talking about she's
this she's that i call booker calls we
get him to book he cancels the debate
with judy mykovitz because god forbid if
she calls him out so these are a bunch
of cowards if you ask me if you have the
audacity to face an opposition if you dr
fauci feel your argument is so solid
come to our podcast go to rogan's
podcast face off somebody let's see a
real good debate that's who i respect if
you're that confident you're right i'm
not the expert i'm not the doctor i'm
not the virologist go debate a
virologist that disagrees with you and
let american people learn what's wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
that how does that benefit people in
power so but the solution he asked what
the solution is to me the solution is
debates to me the solution is let's put
a debate guess what remember that one
girl that represents the nra what's the
girl's name that represents nra the
attractive girl dana lash she's a beast
right guess what they do a town hall
meeting have you seen this town hall
meeting that they did with dana lash and
they brought a cop and they brought all
these guys it was like seven against one
against daniel can you pull up dana lash
debate town hall whatever it was just to
show the picture images not video you
know what she does here's what she does
she sits there
in front of nearly 10 15 000 people i
don't know how big the audience is and
she debates everybody makes her point
they make fun of her
that guy disagrees with her she simply
sits there and gives her case
every boo
boo it is the most disrespectful session
towards her but she had the audacity to
sit and face off representing the nra
i'd love to see fauci sit against
somebody that disagrees with them but no
god forbid we can't have debate today in
america he's a handshake if he gets a
question from a bit we cannot have a
debate on america today so that i think
is a solution and we have a problem
because your solution is have debates
i agree with you that's an
understatement yeah okay it's all
understood like sanjay gupta went on
rogan he had he gave him tough questions
respected props to him for doing that
what's your solution
but it goes beyond debates we we my
solution is to admit reality
right right now they're trying to social
engineers one of the stories we may not
get to is about thomas paine and that's
just indicative of every this is one of
the american founding fathers
and if you post a quote from him
your page gets taken down so it goes
beyond it's not about not even having
the debate
now they're actually suppressing they're
suppressing information
that's counter to the narrative the
narrative is all
power is that's all i agree with you i
actually full on full-on agree with you
but how does that handle covet what do
you mean
dude
can we even have a discussion on what's
real and what's not on covid my page got
demonetized my facebook page 125 000
subscribers demonetized for saying guys
this very clearly came from a lab in
wuhan a year and a half later everybody
now admits that my page is still
demonetized it'll never come back
probably right so if you're fighting
against an apparatus all right that has
all the power
and they are trying to social engineer a
reality that doesn't exist
right what
you're saying what the solution to that
is the solution to covet in particular
this isn't this is no longer about covet
this hasn't been about covett for a long
time covet isn't the issue government's
reaction to covet is the issue people
have figured out how to live with covet
people have figured out how to
survive in this world a lot of people
you can't like for example when when the
guy in texas died of omnicron you know
and everybody all over the we have our
first omnicrom death it turned out some
intrepid journalist one if there's left
in the world called up and said can you
confirm the coroner's office can you
confirm that this guy died of goes well
he died with we don't know if he died of
it right so whoa why won't you say he
died oh well because we really can't
confirm if he died of it it was present
in his body at the time of death
so now how many of these deaths how much
of this hysteria
right can be re-diagnosed i think debate
is a solution to be honest with you
i agree for me i love the fact that
these guys are being held accountable
that somebody can push them and say i
disagree with you but you the word
disagree you can't use today
we sit here and we talk and what do you
say i don't know if i agree with you
guys with the home pricing i think so
many people that are buying a house and
they can't even afford two years a day
they lose outside
guess what fantastic let the audience
sit there and say i agree with adam tom
has no clue what he's talking about i
screw pat i agree with tom i don't know
about gerrard i agree with gerard pat
how do you have to be we can't have that
at the next level pat how do you have
debate at the next level serious
question how do you have debate if dr
mike says the company line and gets 10x
the amount of views yeah and if you want
to see the solution he has a solution
but my rebuttal to you is the following
rebuttal first of all
um
you know uh uh you know how when these
guys get into a ring and they get
knocked out and it's like oh my gosh
what a [ __ ] the guy got knocked out
look at his ass freaking embarrassing it
was terrible yeah the guy in the ring
tyrone woodley no no all i'm trying to
say is he had the audacity they're not
tyrone moodley anybody anybody he had
the audacity to get in the ring right
like i i hate to watch fedor's last 10
fights
because it's just hard for me to watch
his last 10 fights because it's like you
know it's it's a fedora's a fader like a
legend right yeah here's a point trump
got into it with anybody you want to cnn
you want to buy you think if cnn invited
trump today he'd go on tv tomorrow do
you think if msnbc by the trump he's
going to miss mcc tomorrow like this
he's not afraid when's the last time you
saw biden on fox news
yeah never but but again when's the last
time you stopped biting on fox news so
now let me go back to him on the
question here bernie goes on fox news
though that's why i respect bernie what
have you heard me say about bernie i
think bernie's a true believer i don't
think biden's a true believer here's the
point i want to give the answer to to
gerard so he said i think there's a
major uh what did you say about the
democratic party there's a civil war
going on right i think there's a civil
war also going on a little bit on the
republican party it's always the other
party that's got the civil well the
republican party doesn't have a civil
war who's a spokesperson for the
republican party who's got to be trump
no i'm not talking like not the like you
know how you said the real powerful
person for the democrats is
but the point is who's that guy behind
closed doors it ain't car world used to
be 20 years ago who was that guy today
who's sitting there saying hey stop
bitching
stop bitching
stop allowing a freaking forbes to be
sold to china 95 the next time twitter's
on sale buy the damn company take talk
usas for sales buy the damn company like
remember when trump pushed tick tock
where tick tock was forced to sell to a
us-based company do you guys remember
that story yeah i don't know if you
remember or not
why didn't somebody buy it
the koch brothers are too busy still in
petrochemicals that's the problem right
there so if you really want to play
one of them that's right that's right if
you really want to play the game if you
really want to play the game against the
opponent be a little bit of a better
opponent you're not a good opponent
right now republicans are not a good
opponent right now just so you know
they're not the most unified brilliant
strategic now yeah they're just sitting
there saying leave me alone let me do my
thing i'm going to make my money i'm
going to be good they don't realize one
day they're going to wake up and realize
there's something that's got more
currency than money
and that money that as much as
as much wealth as you got there's
something called regulation and laws and
controlling and dictating what you need
to do and what kind of a life you're
going to live there's nothing you can
say about the laws that we can create we
can ruin your life all your billions
good for you we don't give a [ __ ] do as
we say or else
but who do you think it is but the
amazing point by the way who do i think
it is yeah i don't think there's anybody
it's just they just
watch trump and they just do what he
says is there anybody behind closed
doors that's actually running on the
show
libertarians the crypto libertarians
might save us after all who knows maybe
i think they're good for society
last quick story here funny story to
wrap up with alexa tells 10 year old
girl to touch live plug with a penny now
whether this is a mistake or not it's an
interesting story i don't know if it's
that funny no it's not it's an alexa
tells 10 year old girl to touch live
plug with a penny bbc story amazon has
updated his alexa voice assistant after
challenged a 10 year old girl it
challenged a 10 year girl to touch a
coin
to the prongs of a half inserted plug
the suggestion came after the girl asked
alexa for a challenge to do plug in the
phone charger about halfway into the
wall outlet then touch a penny to the
exposed prongs the smart speaker said
the dangerous activity known as a penny
challenge began circulating on tick tock
and other social media websites about a
year ago metals conduct electricity and
inserting them into a live electrical
sockets can cause electrical shocks fire
and other damage
how bad is this for alexa by the way
alexa just searched the web for
challenges and just said the first thing
that it came up it came up because that
was the thing that was
that's uh that's uh yeah you know it's
so funny we got all these movies about
how like skynet takes over and it's a
whole bunch of terminators coming but
it's that's not going to be it at all we
have an entire generation that that just
listens to everything is this on alexa
is this on amazon is this on the parent
is this on the kid who's this on the
jeff bezos and his population
small design flaw in it's just yeah
alexa looks up well who do you think
it's on should a 10 year old kid have
access to alexa no yeah that's what i'm
saying
no i that's what i'm saying well the mom
likes that alexa the mom was there this
is on tick tock for its mom dumbass no
challenges like the bleach challenge and
the tie
i don't know well let me tell you
something wasn't there a funny one with
alexa where her kid
i think this is on a thousand dollars
you've got a 10 year old sitting around
there alexa play scarface what she's
saying is she's saying that the mom was
there playing the game against alexa so
i don't know that's the it's a good
publicity stunt for something to go
viral is it going to hurt alexis sales
do you think alexa is going to be hurt
by this i don't think it's going to do
anything i mean there's no i feel like
this is obviously bad for alexa but then
then you have someone this is obviously
a 10 year old girl then you have
jalen maxwell that's looking at this and
being like oh it can get worse
maybe we'll talk about the tomorrow
we're brandon shop folks tomorrow's
podcast is at one o'clock
not at nine o'clock it'll be with
brandon shop tomorrow at one o'clock
uh right here yes brandon
maybe tomorrow one o'clock
join us on the podcast tomorrow this
will be a three week three day a week
this week we've done it because we
didn't do anything last week tomorrow
one o'clock eastern standard time put it
in the calendar great podcast guys
awesome stuff take care everybody
bye-bye bye-bye happy new year guys
you